bonjour mon andros qui merci de répondre
à nos questions sur rt france à l'elysée
évoque donc au menu des discussions
ce fameux dialogue stratégique franco
russe anton claireaux vient de nous en
parler
mais concrètement dialogue stratégique
ça veut dire quoi bruno brusque et ça
veut dire qu'en fait les deux pays se
parle parce que évidemment comme on l'a
vu il ya un vif il ya différentes pays
qui sont touchés par des crises et que
la france ou la russie ou les deux sont
mêlés à ces différentes crises donc
l'ukraine la syrie la libye donc ça
c'est évidemment un aspect des choses
qui est essentiel auquel je rajouterais
le fait que recèle t on en vit dans une
période de grande incertitude
avec tout ce qui se passe aux etats-unis
avec l'année électorale d'abord aux
états unis puis tous les problèmes
récents qui se sont développées aux
états unis et qui font que très
certainement les chefs d'état cherche
des points de de stabilité dans un monde
qui est de plus en plus instable et bien
sûr la russie
quoi qu'on pense macro emmanuel macron
et plus largement les dirigeants
occidentaux est quand même un pôle de
stabilité et donc on peut supposer que
parler avec moscou c'est une façon de se
rattacher à quelque chose d'à peu près
très visible alors que de l'autre côté
de l'atlantique on se retrouve devant
une situation imprévisible ukraine libye
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à des
avancées concrètes dans ces différents
dossiers
on pourrait l'espérer c'est vrai que la
dernière fois sur le cren on a très peu
avancé qui a eu entre temps des tensions
dans le dos de base donc les choses
n'ont pas semblé vraiment avancer donc
on peut espérer évidemment que les
choses avancent tout dépendra si tous
les poulets toutes les tous les états
engagés dans le temps le contenu
craignent un sont prêts à faire avancer
les choses
même chose en syrie où il n'y a pas que
la russie et la france qui sont engagés
loin de là puisqu'il ya les états unis
et la turquie et c'est la même chose en
libye
donc là on peut penser qu'on a deux pays
qui discutent et qui vont peut-être se
mettre d'accord pour essayer d'amener
les autres puissances à conclure un
compromis était trop tôt pour le dire
mais pour dire qu'est ce qu'il en
adviendra mais il est très certainement
question d'essayer d'avancer de
clarifier les choses autant à moscou car
paris est de passer par dessus des
divergences pour essayer de stabiliser
la situation je pense que c'est
l'essentiel de ce qui se passe en ce
moment c'est la recherche de stabilité
pour pour un monde qui est de plus en
plus instable qui est en position de
force dans cet échange entre la france
et la russie
jusqu'à récemment c'est certainement la
russie puisque la russie a marqué quand
même un certain nombre de points au
cours des deux années précédentes
au moins pour des deux années
précédentes alors que la france était en
état de aussi d'affaiblissement
donc on peut dire que la russie apparaît
comme comme comme un pays solide
à quoi s'ajoute évidemment encore un
autre élément c'est que là la situation
internationale a mis de l'avant une
autre puissance qui est la chine et il
est clair que pour les pays d'europe
enfin d'europe occidentale se placer
dans le grand jeu avec la russie et par
rapport à la sint aussi quelque chose
d'important et là je pense aussi qu'il
ya besoin de consultation entre paris et
moscou pour savoir exactement
lequel des deux acteurs à quelles
intentions par rapport à la question
chinoise et aux tensions que l'on auquel
on assiste entre les états unis et la
chine
cette visioconférence intervient presque
un an après la venue du chef du kremlin
au fort de brégançon c'était le 19 août
dernier en un an
qu'est ce qui a changé dans les
relations paris moscou on se souvient
notamment du discours du président
français à l'automne dernier face aux
diplomates au quai d'orsay il prenait un
rapprochement avec la russie l'europe va
de lisbonne à vladivostok on se souvient
de cette phrase d'emmanuel macron oui
moi je pense que ce qui a changé c'est
le fait que d'abord ctp les dirigeants
des deux pays se parlent régulièrement
et qu'on est définitivement semble-t-il
quand même sortis de la période de
méfiance systématique
qui avait précédé au cours des années
précédentes
déjà sous la présidence du président
macro mais même avant et donc en ce sens
cela on peut dire que je sais pas si on
peut dire que la glace est rompue mais
tout au moins on je parle et on se parle
régulièrement et on on essaie de se
positionner par rapport à l'autre sur la
scène internationale merci bruno drôle
ce qui est d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
historien et maître de conférences à
l'inalco l'institut des langues et des
civilisations orientales